the Joe Rogan experience I don't want to
get off me but like how how was that
spacing at this venue for you during the
fight because because it sounded like
y'all are next to each other and then I
heard like in a story yard separate it
we were about as far as Jamie is about
as far as John annek was and then DC was
like a little further than that because
there was a separation there's a like
the Octagon post and so for him to get a
better angle he couldn't be sitting
right in front of the post so they moved
his table like another he was probably
15 20 feet from me somewhere around that
where people do you feel that I feel
like fighter you know fighters are tough
you know and I feel like the audience is
tough too and the people associated with
it is tough did they move around freely
or was it really like oh I need to stay
away from or here's the deal
everyone was tested everyone in fact one
guy tested positive he was asymptomatic
shocker I saw who was on the card yep
and he had an inkling that he might test
positive because he had a family member
that had it and he was super healthy
ready to fight but had it in his system
and so they removed him from the card
and he had been wearing a mask and
gloves the entire time he was there and
everyone else had wrist bands on the
wristband showed that you'd been tested
they had temperature monitors he had all
these different things but everybody had
been tested thoroughly tested for
antibodies tested for this swag I got
the swab up the nose I got everything
done so Wow and then when I got home I
immediately got swab again I got a swab
yesterday and then I got the vitamin
drip and everything like that oh I
didn't get much sleep
Saturday night cuz I was flying back
eight o'clock in the morning fights were
done I was back to my hotel around 2:30
so I crashed woke up early got to the
airport took off landed and then just
kind of took it easy yesterday but until
I got the vitamin drip I was dragging I
was feeling but and that's what happens
when you fly and you'd flown a couple of
times for a period of time and then that
drive to Vegas all that stuff you have
to think of your immune system like
troops you know you really do if there's
a battle to be fought you're you're look
if your body was like your mom's where
you you know you had
a good night's sleep every night no
traveling you can fight off a lot more
[ __ ] but when you do those trips
especially this is one thing that I'm
getting out of this quarantine is man I
feel so much better when I don't travel
oh yeah so much better when I wasn't
dying I feel great I feel great now I
feel great now yeah rest is a big thing
it's everything it's everything
everything and you know I'm gonna change
my travel schedule in the future because
even this trip this trip I wanted to
just get in and get the [ __ ] out of
Florida and get back home and and you
know but then after I did it I was like
it would been wiser if I left it like 6
p.m. or something like that like just
kind of chill out give myself plenty
time to sleep sleep some fully recovered
and then you know have some breakfast
then go to the airport you know take a 3
p.m. flight or some [ __ ] how was it with
nobody in there did you enjoy the
experience I wanted to do it because
I've never done that before and I
watched the one card from Brazil they
had Kevin Lee versus Charles Oliveira
fought in Brazil and I watched on TV and
I was like god that's so strange because
like Gilbert Burns he knocked out Demian
Maia and then he he yells out poha you
know there's something Brazilian saying
and empty arena and I was watching like
that's so strange
he's screaming and there's no one there
there's no no audience reaction like wow
so I decided like I got a do one so when
Dana White asked me if I wanted to do it
I was like yay I want do one I
definitely wanted do you feel like the
fighters were listening to go 100% were
they they made adjustments because
things that DC said so Cormier you know
we're all right so or that wrote that
close oh yeah well we're at the Octagon
okay we're still at the Octagon we're
right in front of the Octagon okay I
could reach up and touch the Octagon
so when wow it's actually a little bit
further than we usually are but still
and closer now like like where that wall
is okay where the Octagon is pretty
close and you know DC's giving them
points he's like pointers he's saying
you know he's got to check those leg
kicks and
making adjustments like he was talking
about Carlos Barza and Carla Esparza
backstage gave DC credit for like what
what the advice that he was saying in
the commentary was the adjustments that
she'd made that's great yeah I was weird
you know I loved watching like I watched
the prelims but I loved it because you
could hear everything because normally
so loud yeah but when somebody hits
somebody it's in the face you could hear
it but especially to the body yeah oh my
is like a thump yeah and then you hear
the other person yeah I'm it changed the
game for me on UFC where you I think a
lot of people appreciate it more with
not having a crowd yell where you really
get to feel the pain mm-hmm because when
it's loud you don't you see somebody
fall but you don't really okay it's
enough but when you hear it yeah
there's different things going on right
it's like there's the energy of the
crowd that that's a factor that's a real
thing like there's something magical
about a wild finish in front of a packed
house at the t-mobile Arena yeah
everybody's screaming and cheering like
wow or like when Conor McGregor walked
to the Octagon and everybody's going
crazy there's something to that it's
valuable
[Applause]